i'm just going to say it right now the
pittsburgh steelers
are the best team in football
they're the best team in football
because
oh i like that i like it
i got to think about it listen i'm not
going to disappear okay i'm going to
think about it
let me think about it i'm going to tell
you why i feel like they're the best all
right
other other teams have some area
that is better than pittsburgh for
example team playing tonight
kansas city has the best quarterback but
they're
playing football the statements are
coming and let's say seattle
and let's say seattle has a better
quarterback yeah than the steelers but
the steelers
and i know oh my man devin bush that's a
big interesting
hate that is that's a big issue
absolutely cause they moved up to get
him
look the steelers they're so interesting
before i talk about the obvious of
ben roethlisberger coming back and we
know how they struggled last year
going down to the third quarterback uh
without roethlisberger last year
but their defense their defense is
legitimate
and i thought i kind of looked uh i
looked at them sideways last year
because mike
this is one of my favorite stats in
football i brought it up before i know
i probably have brought it up 10 times
12 times
but i love this because this kind of
speaks to the culture
of the pittsburgh steelers when they
traded their first round pick
to the miami dolphins last year from
minka fitzpatrick
yeah it was the first time in over
50 years and the pittsburgh steelers did
not have a first round pick
now i thought you were going to talk
about that
how many rounders do they have on
defense but how many first rounds at
that point to him on defense it was some
ridiculous number you know uh i don't
know
nine ten somebody but why wouldn't they
uh you know there's
a lot of first so that defense has been
legit is what i'm saying they were legit
last year quiet as it's kept
and minkah fitzpatrick you know thank
goodness he got him i got out of miami
who didn't know how to use him right
uh but no yeah all right so but you like
i like
the totality or trade those picks and
trade out of the first round move up
yeah
they have just been steady but uh the
trade for mika fitzpatrick you saw
yesterday with the uh with the
interception return for a touchdown
so i like their defense their defense is
incredible i like their head coach we've
talked about him before he's a top five
coach but nobody ever describes him
that way they got a very good uh
quarterback
got a good old line the receivers are
always good i just look
across the board they're the best team
of football and there's the stat right
there
that's the stat right there that tripped
me out like in their glorious history
this is only the second time they've
been 5-0 that's kind of hard to believe
and first time
that is 1978 the super bowl uh 13 season
i believe when it be dallas 35 31.
um oh nice but no listen look at you
look at you oh yeah
you know what hey man you're a trip
you're a trooper because you know you
try to do that casually
that's like one of your things that's
like one of your quirks i don't know if
people know that
like michael smith just kind of has
super bowl history at his fingertips
you know i remember certain things i
can't remember yesterday
i can't remember people's names but you
know super bowl is but i just
random random facts
you know who played super bowl 20. you
probably got the score yeah there's
patriots yeah
so look at that i see okay okay you're
just you're just showing off now
but no uh yeah 40 anyway i'll see our
yeah 46 10 was that the score it was six
was it forty six patriots were up threes
open that game
wait but i also remember what you said
had a lead i don't remember what i say
but i remember what you said
and just last week i kind of feel like
you used the r
word as it relates to this game going
into this game you use the r word i'm
like really
like just because they might you know
they may not like each other
i don't know if that constitution is is
it a rivalry when they still have it
right now since 2003
it is i mean it's okay i know well it's
a rivalry for me
the reason i bring that up it's a rival
for me
okay michael you know what hey man
ohioans they call it a rivalry
it's not a rivalry when you can't
hold a candle to them historically
ginger or
ginger's contemporary too hey look man
fine okay i just i guess i guess
bruised canadians will always be a
rivalry yankees red sox will always
always be a rivalry whether one team is
good or not it just is
it is yeah i that's all at least there
has to be some
level of equality when it comes you got
to win what you can't go
20 years almost without winning in other
people's stadium to be a robbery
but i'm saying but for me the reason i
bring that up is for me yesterday said
more about the browns than it did about
steelers i already knew that the
steelers were legit i knew they were
i kind of fell for being a believer in
the browns when
the times that they played anybody worth
a damn this year baltimore and
pittsburgh
they've lost 38 to 7. so you know what
michael i'm making an executive decision
it's going to take an active it's going
to take a significant news story
for me to talk about the browns on this
show moving forward and if and when we
do
it is not going to be within the context
of the browns for real
i know baker's ribs were beat up i know
he was injured blah blah blah
there's always some reason why they
don't show up when they have to show up
there's always some reason
you know i spent the last few weeks like
oh look at the browns first time don't
make it four game winning streak since
1994
and invoking the name of bill belichick
and all this kind of stuff they ain't
ready for prime time you want to talk
about not being on my next football
they ain't ready for primetime the
browns ain't ready and they showed it
again yesterday
okay and they showed it in week one when
it when we coming into the season they
were high hopes for the browns
only for them to have the ravens you
know beat the brakes off
them here's another repeat of that until
further notice i don't talk about the
bronzes contenders
or as a playoff team or any of that kind
of stuff
i don't hear oh yeah they're not they're
not for real they're not foreign
we overreacted going into the game all
this buildup
they had our miles all water for some
mouth water for some orange juice and he
left us with a swallow orange juice
you know we wanted some hash and orange
juice and here come the browns losing
30. it was
24 to nothing it was never competitive
it was one of the more key match-ups of
week six
to never be competitive i don't want to
talk about the problems anymore
hey as i i'm sure as as a the coach that
we will talk too soon will tell you
hey a couple plays here or there could
be a different game you know things kind
of went left and
then it turned out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports